ROCHELLE, THANK YOU.
FEDERAL SHUTDOWN CONTINUES.
DEMOCRATS COALESCE AROUND A
RATIONALE FOR CONTINUED
OPPOSITION TO A BORDER WALL.
THEY ARE NO LONGER TELLING
YOU WALLS ARE TOO EXPENSIVE.
THAT WAS A LAUGHABLE
ARGUMENT COMING FROM THE
LEFT THEY HAVE GIVEN UP.
NOT TELLING YOU WALLS DON'T
WORK BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THEY
DO.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT THE
PROBABLE THEY ARE NOW
TELLING US, YOU JUST HEARD
IT, IS THAT GOD DOESN'T LIKE
WALLS.
THEY ARE IMMORAL.
AS BETO O'ROURKE NOTED THE
OTHER DAY WALLS, QUOTE,
ENSURE DEATH.
BUILDING THE WALL IS THE
SAME AS COMMITTING MURDER.
DEMOCRAT LAMAR OF MINNESOTA
HAS BEEN IN CONGRESS A
MATTER OF WEEKS.
ALREADY SHE STRONGLY AGREES
WITH THIS.
>> AND I DEMAND THAT THE
PRESIDENT END HIS TEMPER
TANTRUMS AND QUEST FOR A
RACIST AND SINFUL BIG WALL.
>> Tucker: RACIST AND
XENOPHOBIC THAT'S WHAT WALLS
ARE.
ONCE YOU UNDERSTAND THAT IT
DOES MAKE YOU THINK THERE
ARE AN AWFUL LOT OF WALLS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
NOW WE KNOW THEY ARE AN
OFFENSE AGAINST GOD, HOW CAN
WE LET THEM STAND?
THAT'S A REAL QUESTION FOR
THE CITY OF EL PASO, TEXAS.
EL PASO IS ON THE BORDER
RIGHT ACROSS FROM JUAREZ,
MEXICO.
EL PASO WAS A CALM AND
PEACEFUL AND GREAT PLACE.
JUAREZ IS VIOLENT AND
CHAOTIC.
ONE OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
CITIES IN THE WORLD.
HOW CAN THESE TWO PLACES
EXIST SIDE BY SIDE?
SIMPLE.
THERE IS A WALL BETWEEN
THEM.
CONGRESSWOMAN VERONICA
ESCABAR NOW REPRESENTS THE
CITY OF EL PASO.
SHE JUST REPLACED BETO
O'ROURKE.
SHE SAYS IT MAY BE TIME TO
KNOCK DOWN THAT SINFUL WALL.
>> WE KNOW THAT WALLS DON'T
WORK.
THAT THEY DON'T STOP
MIGRATION.
>> EL PASO HAS A WALL.
YOU SAY IT DOESN'T WORK.
WOULD YOU EVER CALL FOR THE
REMOVAL OF THE WALL THERE?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S REALLY
UGLY.
IT IS -- I THINK A MONUMENT
TO DIVISION.
WE HAVE ALWAYS HAD FENCING
ALONG THE U.S.-MEXICO
BORDER.
IT'S EXISTED -- I'M A
LIFELONG RESIDENT IT ALWAYS
WAS THERE THE BIGGER AND
TALLER AND YOU RECALLIER
THAT THEY GET, THEY REALLY
JUST BECOME SIMPLE.
SINFUL.
>> Tucker: SHE IS RIGHT.
WALL DOES DIVIDE.
THAT'S THE POINT OF HAVING
THEM.
THERE ARE SOME THINGS PEOPLE
WOULD LIKE TO BE DIVIDED
FROM LIKE ENDEMIC CORRUPTION
AND MURDEROUS DRUG CARTELS.
HOW DO YOU ACCOMPLISH THAT
WITHOUT WALLS?
WELL, NANCY PELOSI HAS BEEN
THINKING ABOUT THIS
RECENTLY.
HERE'S HER SOLUTION.
>> AND THEN WE TALK ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY, AS I SAID,
SEVERAL HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS RANGES FROM HALF A
BILLION TO $700 MILLION FOR
THE TECHNOLOGY TO SCAN THE
CARS COMING THROUGH THE
PORTS OF ENTRY AND THAT IS
TO DETECT GUNS.
IT'S LIKE AN ELECTRONIC DOG
ALMOST.
DETECT DRUGS, GUNS, AND
OTHER CONTRABAND.
>> Tucker: AN ELECTRONIC
DOG.
OF COURSE, HOW OBVIOUS.
IT WAYS RIGHT THERE IN PLAIN
SIGHT AND WE MISSED IT
SECURITY IN OLD FASHIONED
MID EVIL TERMS, WALLS,
FENCES, ACTUAL LIVING DOGS.
BUT LEAVE IT TO THE
CONGRESSWOMAN FROM OUR
TECHNOLOGY CAPITAL OUT IN
CALIFORNIA TO THINK A LOT
BIGGER THAN THAT YOU ARE
LOOKING AT THE SOLUTION OF
THE FUTURE.
AN ELECTRONIC DOG.
BRILLIANT.
THE SHOW IS EXCLUSIVELY
OBTAINED A PROTOTYPE OF THE
SPEAKER'S DIGITAL CANINE.
YOU ARE WATCHING IT RIGHT
NOW.
JUST KIDDING.
WE PULLED THAT OFF THE
INTERNET.
PROBABLY NOT SO DIFFERENT
FROM THE REAL THING THOUGH.
WE WILL SEE.
IN THE MEANTIME LET'S TAKE
NANCY PELOSI AND BETO
O'ROURKE AND THE ENTIRE
EDITORIAL STAFFS ON THE
OTHER CABLE CHANNELS
SERIOUSLY FOR A MOMENT.
LET'S CONCEDE THAT WALLS
ARE, IN FACT, INHERENTLY
IMMORAL, HOW DO WE RESPOND
ONCE WE HAVE ACCEPTED THAT?
WE CAN'T SIMPLY PREVENT
DONALD TRUMP FROM BUILDING A
WALL.
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH.
WE HAVE GOT TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THE COUNTLESS WALLS OF
WICKEDNESS THAT DEGRADE AND
POLLUTE AMERICA'S POLAR
LANDSCAPE.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE WALL THAT
KEEPS POOR PEOPLE OUT OF
BARACK OBAMA'S HOME IN
WASHINGTON.
THE WALL THAT PROTECTS
GEORGE SOROS' PLACE IN SOUTH
HAMPTON.
THE WALL AT THE PELOSI
COMPOUND IN NAPA NOT TO
MENTION THE WALL AROUND MARK
ZUCKERBERG'S ESTATE IN
HAWAII.
THINK GATED COMMUNITIES OF
BRENTWOOD THE WALLS AND
GARDENS OF BROOKLYN.
LEVEL THEM ALL.
ALL OF THEM.
MAKE THEM FLAT.
IN FACT, DO IT TONIGHT FOR
AN ANGRY GOD TURNS US ALL TO
PAY LARRS OF SALT FOR
IGNORING ANTI-WALL.
SPEAKER PELOSI, TEAR DOWN
THESE WALLS.
ONCE HAVE YOU DONE THAT TURN
THE BULLDOZER OF
RIGHTEOUSNESS OUTWARD TO THE
WORLD.
ISRAEL FOR EXAMPLE
SURROUNDED BY WALLS ON ALL
SIDES.
DOES INDIANAPOLIS KNOW THAT?
WOULD SHE WITHHOLD BILLIONS
IN MILITARY AID UNTIL THEIR
WALLS ARE GONE?
WHAT'S A MORAL QUESTION NOW.
WHAT'S THE ANSWER?
HOW ABOUT TO YOUR KNOWLEDGE TUNS
HOW ABOUT TO YOUR KNOWLEDGE TUNA
HOW ABOUT TO YOUR KNOWLEDGE TUND
JORDAN?
I WOULD IMPLICATED IN THOSE
WALLS.
WILL WE PAY TO TAKE THEM
DOWN?
HOW MUCH DO WE REALLY CARE
ABOUT OUR SOULS?
WE CONTACTED THE SPEAKER
TODAY TO FIND OUT.
SHE DIDN'T REPLY.
NEITHER DID THE OTHER
DEMOCRATS WE CALLED.
IT TURNS OUT THEY HAVE NO
PLAN TO ELIMINATE ANYONE
ELSE'S WALLS AND CERTAINLY
NOT THEIR OWN.
THEY JUST DON'T WANT A WALL
TO PROTECT AMERICA.
THEY DON'T THINK OUR COUNTRY
DESERVES THAT YESTERDAY A
MAN
AAN
ATHE "NEW YORK TIMES" RAN A
WALL.
HE DEMANDED U.S. GET RID OF
BORDERS ENTIRELY.
A BILLION PEOPLE WANT TO
MOVE HERE, SO BE IT.
IT'S NOT OUR RIGHT TO KEEP
THEM OUT.
IT'S ONLY OUR OBLIGATION TO